[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد تتواصلوا تساؤلات حول
تكتم القاعده المستاجن في اعلان مقتل
قائدها ايمن الظواهري رسميا حتى الان وعدم
الاعلان الرسمي عن خليفه اللهب فتنضم الى
اليوم لا يزال يرفض الاعتراف بفقدان ايمن
الظواهري بضربه النفذتها طائره من دون
طيار في كابول العام الماضي وهنا ركز
تحرير تحليل الاخباري ونشرته وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه العثبي على تفسير
الاسباب وراء تكتم تنظيم القاعده على
خليفه الزعيم السابق ايمن الظواهري الذي
اعلنت واشنطن عن مقتله قبل خمسه اشهر غير
ان الصمت المتعمد يراه بعض المراقبين
عجزنا من طرف القاعده التي فشلت في
الاتصال بسيف العدل الخليفه المفترض
للظواهر الذي يختبئ في ايران والذي يعيش
في بيئه خطيره تحد من حركته في حين تشير
بعض التقديرات الى ان صوت القاعده فرضته
عليها بيبان والتي اا قررت عدم التعليق
على قتل الظواهري الذي يمكن ان يكون جزءا
من جهودها لاداره علاقتها مع القاعده
وايضا واشنطن ومن هنا فان صمت الجماعه
بشان ما بعد الظواهر الذي عين بعد سته
اسابيع فقط من مقتل ابن لادن يعكس الضعف
الحاليه الواضح لتنظيمه القاعده
[موسيقى]
ونتابع الموضوع لماذا لم تعلن القاعده حتى
الان مقتل زعيمها ايمن الظواهري من
القاهره مع العميد الدكتور خالد عكاشه
مدير المركز المصري للفكر والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك من الرياض عبر
سكايب الزميله هدى
الصالحات
لماذا لم تعلن القاعده حتى الان رسميا عن
مقتل زعيمها ايمن الظواهري
احنا ممكن نشوفها بعده جوانب وعده اسباب
اول شيء طبعا في ادانه لحركه طالبان
باستضافه الظواهري في المنزل الرسمي
التابع للطيافه لهم ايضا هناك صراع بين
قيادات التنظيم نفسها ما بين قيادات تنظيم
في اليمن وما بين سيف العادل وشخص كانوا
قريبين من الظواهري انا سيف العدل لم تكن
علاقته جيده مع ايمن الظواهري
فطبعا هو اللي متذكر احنا احنا
حمزه بن لادن ايضا لم يعترف بمقتلها تنظيم
القاعده
وكذلك تنظيم كذلك حركه الطالبان المولى
عمر لم يكشف عن وفاته همم خلال سنتين ونصف
ومن فضح وفاه عمر كان تنظيم داعش همم عاده
التنظيمات والجماعات المسلحه تغيب يعني
خبر ونبا مقتل مؤسسها يعني همم يعني
للاشياء اللي بتنعكس على مسار هذا
التنظيمي لاحقا فتحب ان تعيش في ظل
وشبح الزعيم الاول المؤسس له طبعا لم يحصل
مع بن لادن مثلا عندما قتل بن لادن مباشره
كان هناك الاعلان من قبل القاعده وطبعا
وتسميه الظواهر زعيم للتنظيم لماذا هذه
المره هناك هذا التكتم
لديه رجل ثاني في التنظيم وان كان اقل
كارميه واقل الجماهيريا وسط القاعده
العامه لتنظيم نفسه لكن كان عنده الحضور
يعني فلديه شخصيه احتياطيه لكن اذا بنشوف
التنظيمات اخرى مثلا او بكر البغدادي اه
كان هو الشخصيه الرئيسيه الجوهريه للتنظيم
بعد مقتله اعتمد التنظيم لمجرد شخصيات كما
لا تظهر صوتها حتى الاسماء حتى المقتل
الزعيم
لانهم يفتقرون الى كاريزمه البغدادي
لا ليست وجهه نظري يعني ليست لاسباب
تنظيميه لان التنظيم يحتاج عاده ان يكون
لديه شخصيه هامه ومحوريه حتى يستقطب من
جديد وياخذ بيعات على اساسها
تنظيم شخصيه خاصه عن تجمع الصفوف يعني
عنها
اخرى ما هو تفسير ما هي قراءتك هناك عده
فرضيات المحللون يذهبون بعده اتجاهات من
بينها انه ربما قد يكون الامريكيون قد
اخطاوا لم يقتلوا الظواهر حقا وهذا مستعد
طبعا ولكن هناك حديث على انه كما قالت همم
الاستاذ هدى انه ممكن يكون رفع حرج عن
طالبان لانه قتل في همم كابل
وهناك فرضيات اخرى انه خليفه هو موجود
اصلا في ايران وايران ايضا لها دور في ذلك
انت ما رايك لماذا لم يعلن رسميا حتى الان
همم مقتل ظهري وتسميه خليفه له على راس
تنظيم القاعده
همم تحياتي لحضرتك
والاستاذ هدى والاستاذه المشاهدين جميعا
همم يعني ربما اميل اكثر الى ان اا تغيير
اعلان خليفه لايمن الظواهري ربما يعكس حجم
الازمه والماظه الذي يعيش تنظيم القاعده
ربما هذا المؤزر وهذه الازمه ممتده همم
حتى همم في السنوات الاخيره من وجود ايمن
الظاهري همم تنظيم القاعده همم يعاني من
هشاشه كبيره في القياده المركزيه وظهر هذا
الامر بشكل جليل همم في السنوات الاخيره
لايمن الظواهري وكثيرا تحدثنا بان فروع
تنظيم القاعده اصبحت هي الاكبر والاقوى من
القياده المركزيه ما بعد بن لادن همم حصرت
الاضواء والقدرات ايضا عن القياده
المركزيه وكان سقوط طالبان في الغزو
الامريكي كان نازعا كبيرا لقدرات هذه
القياده المركزيه لصالح التنظيمات الفرعيه
لصالح الفروع التي اا ترسخت في مناطقها
بشكل اا اكبر كثيره وتمتعت بقدر واسع من
اللامركزيه
وانخرطت في ساحات العمل الوطنيه او
المحليه التي اا تعيش فيها مما جعلها
تستخدم فقط الشعار القاعدي كنوع من انواع
الانتماء التاريخي لكن من دون اا وجود
حاله مؤسسيه كما قارنت حضرتك واستاذ هدى
في النهايه في نهايه الحديث السابق ما بين
القاعده وداعش وهديه مقارنه همم منطقيه
وجيده وكانت الاجابه صحيحه بان همم داعش
لديه طابع مؤسسي اا جعل خليفه ابو بكر
البغدادي او مجموعه الخلفاء التي تولوا من
بعد ابو بكر البغدادي كانوا حاضرين وسريع
التحديد والاعلان حتى اا رغم تعرضهم
لعمليات اغتيال في فتره زمنيه وجهه لكن
استطاعت تنظيم ان يقدم بدائل
بخلفيه طبعه المؤسسه الذي تفقر ولكن دكتور
خالد التحليله كم مهم جدا في مساله انه لو
كان القاعده الان قويه يعني مثل ما كان او
كان لديه القوه كان يعني اختاره زعيم له
واظهره وجعله يتحدث المفارقه انه هو ما
زال همم يعني يبص بعض الخطابات المسجله
لايمن الظواهري همم الى اي حتى تعتقد ان
القاعده همم تنظيم القاعده قد ضعف في هذه
المرحله همم واكبر دليل عليها عدم اعلان
مقتل الظواهر نفسه
كما اشارنا بالفعل يواجه ضعف لكن في هذه
الجزئيه على وجه التحديد اعود
واؤكد او اؤيد ماذا ذهبت اليه حضرتك ولمحت
اليه استاذه هدى الخاص بوضع حركه طالبان
لانها ليست خارج هذه المعادله بالكليه
بالفعل هناك قدر من الحرج تستشعره طالبان
طلبا تريد ان تقدم نفسها بنسخه جديده بوجه
جديد للمجتمع الدولي كما اشارنا همم
الفروع اصبحت همم كل همم يغني على ليلاكم
لديه همم الاهداف
تتحدث عن الفروع القاعده ان كان في اليمن
ولا في همم في المغرب العربي ولا في مناطق
اخرى هل ماتز هذه الفروع ايضا قادره على
شان هجمات ارهابيه ام لا
بالطبع يعني هنا على وجه التحديد اتحدث عن
الفرع في اليمن اتحدث عن فرع جماعه شباب
في الصومال وايضا
المقر الاكبر وهو منطقه الساحل الافريقي
والقاعده في بلاد المغرب العربي التي
اتخذت مجموعه من الاسماء الجديده مثل
جماعه انصار الاسلام والمسلمين وجماعه
انصار الدينما تنظيمان ينتميان الى
القاعده
وتلك الفروع الثلاث والفرعين الافريقيين
على وجه التحديد اعتقد بانهم يتمتعوا بقوه
كبيره في منطقتهم الجغرافيه حتى جعلت كما
اشرنا جعلهما اقوى بكثير جدا في القدرات
وفي الامكانيات من التنظيم المركزي وربما
هذا التنافر سبب ايضا رئيسي في مساله عدم
اتفاقها هذه الفروع على تعيين قائد همم
يدير مجمل عمل التنظيم
صدق اريد ان اسالك عن علاقه طالبان
والقاعده في هذه المرحله هناك حرج كما
ذكرت كبير وكذلك علاقه ايران مع الاختلاف
طبعا المذهبي ولكن ايران تستفيد كذلك من
تنظيم القاعده في ضغطها على الامريكيين
واحتفاظها باوراق ضغط كيف ترين علاقه
القاعده بطالبان والقاعده
همم بايران بعد مقتل الظواهر
فيها اي شيء بالنسبه مثلا للذكر ابو محمد
المصري الذي قتل في فيران طبعا نفس الامر
اخفت اخفى تنظيم القاعده ولم
اقتراح حتى انخرج ابو حبيب السوداني همم
من اليمن وكاتبه مذكراته واعترف بمقتل ابو
محمد في ايران وانه مقيم في ايران العلاقه
همم يعني قويه جدا سيف العادل يقيم في
ايران وهذه جزء من الاشكالات بحيث ان همم
بعض المصادر من داخل الحركه نفسها همم ترى
بان سيف العدل يوجه تنظيم القاعده في
اليمن وهناك تحالف مع حركه الحوثي في داخل
اليمن
يعني نوع من الخلاف بين الزعامات في هذا
الموضوع وتحديدا ايضا كمان في فرعون في
سوريا
جدا في سوريا وان كانوا غير ظاهرين بشكل
يعني
في الشباك نوعا ما اعلاميه همم بقدر مما
يعني في سوريا همم ايضا بالنسبه لحركه
طالبان طبعا احنا عندنا الجيل الثاني اللي
ابناء القيادات كلهم جميعهم ابو زيدويدا
وابو محمد المصري وايمن الظواهريه يعني
ازهار يعني بنات وابنائه كلهم هذولي
موجودين همم تحتها مظله حركه الطالب لم
تتخلى عنهم ولا تتخلى عنهم وستبقى اوراق
وسيبقى التحالف دائما نفسها لان
الايديولوجيا ولان الاهداف استراتيجيات
كلها مشتركه ومتقاطعه لا يختلف وشيء يعني
الدكتور خالد
عن سيف العدل همم هذا الاسم الذي تردد
كثيرا همم بانه هو همم من يدير القاعده
الان خلفا للظواهر رغم عدم الاعلان الرسمي
للقاعده عن مقتل الظواهر
بطائره من دون طيار امري في كابول همم هل
همم حقا سيف العدل هو الذي هو زعيما
القاعده الحالي
يعني يتمتع سيف العدل بميزتين رئيسيتين
الميزه الاولى باعتباره احد القيادات
التاريخيه واحد اتباع بن لادن المقربين في
كان عنصر رئيسي وقائد الجناح العسكري
لسنوات همم طويله في فتره توهج وازدهار
القاعده في افغانستان همم ولذلك همم يعني
اتجهت اليه ترشيحات بقوه وادار كثير من
النشاط القاعدي في اا فتره ايمن الظواهري
او فتره تولي ايمن الظاهري الميزه الثانيه
انه يقيم في ايران وايران تحتضن تنظيم
القاعده منذ سنوات طويله وهمم جاء السقوط
همم القاعده في افغانستان وكانه هديه
كبيره الى ايران كي تدخل وتخترق التنظيم
بقوه مما جعلها تفتح ابوابها لاحتضان كافه
القيادات الهاربه وابرزها سيف العدل اعتقد
ان احتواء
الاستخبارات الايرانيه
لشخصيه بحجم سيف العدل يجعلها قادره على
توجيه التنظيم لخدمه المشروع الايراني
ولجعل هناك مصالح وارتباطات مع الجماعات
المسلحه الموجوده في المنطقه بشكل كبير
منها الحوثي لكنها لا تقف عند حدود اليمن
ايضا في سوريا وايضا في اجزاء كبيره من
العراق
وصل الامر الى ان هناك اتصالات وارتفاطات
كبيره كشف عنها مؤخرا ما بين القاعده وبين
حزب الله في لبنان هذه الميزه المحوريه
التي يتمتع بها سيف العدل يجعلها تجعله في
المقدمه لكن لا زالت حظوظ من ينافسون في
الجزء الافريقي هي ما تجعل عدم همم
استقبال امر همم اعلانه رسميا وقطعيا بانه
هو الزعيم رقم ثلاثه للقاعده دكتور خالد
عكاشه المركز المصري للفكر والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا لك على قبول دعوه
بانوراما هذا الموسم من القاهره كذلك
الاستاذ هدى الصالح مقدمه ومعدده برنامجات
على منصه العربيه بودكاست شكرا جزيلا لك
على انضمامك الينا الليله من الرياض